hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and welcome to tonight's uh video on
order flow and and today i'm going to be
talking again a little bit more about
delta i want to talk about the delta
footprint and how it can help you see
things that other traders just aren't
aware of right and you know that's the
beauty of order flow is seeing things in
that's taking place in the market that
other traders are just unaware of and
how to take advantage of it you know as
i was going through some of the comments
on
you know the videos the last couple of
days on delta and you know i i love the
comments i'll probably do a video
talking specifically about the comments
and getting back to some of them i did
reply to some and someone was like hey
who's posting that
comment that delta doesn't matter and
i'm like you know hey more power to him
let him tell that to his following so
less people are watching delta because
for those of us that do understand delta
do know what to look for in the delta
it's to our benefit because we're going
to be able to take advantage of stuff
that other people are just dismissing
and
today in the s ps today is what is it
september 7th and
you know market put in a big rally today
but you know there was some
uh some selloffs that came in
and i'm gonna point out a few things in
the delta that can hopefully you know
help you
in your analysis of looking at delta so
this is a regular bid ask footprint
right the volume traded on the bid the
volume traded on the offer and when we
got up to our first high of the day up
here around 8 47 848 this morning you
know there was some big size up there
and if you're looking at the footprint
you could see it now it's a little hard
to see because i got this green line
this green line um is basically the is
the high of the day okay so
i like to keep track of obviously where
the high and the low is and
if you're watching that
you can see the volumes right if you're
looking at the footprint see while 911
uh finally 59 so actually you know
you're hitting that high the first time
trades 900 can't get past it
next
bar trade 702 can't get past it this bar
actually sells off
from 30 all the way down to you know is
that 26 and a quarter comes back up
third time hits it
59 contracts trade so
it's telling you a couple of things one
obviously you know you you got size up
here right you've got um i mean 900 760
you know you're looking already around
1600 contracts that actually traded
there's probably more behind it because
what's happening is traders are coming
up here they're buying it they're trying
to take it to go higher but there's a
big offer up in here and you know it's
probably iceberg and hidden in honestly
i was in front of the screen this
morning at that time i was uh busy with
my kids school stuff
this morning so you know i kind of
missed it then
started kicking myself because sometimes
these things are so clear when you're
looking at a delta footprint but if
you're just looking at a normal order
flow footprint unless you know what to
look at and can see that you're running
into that size and what is important is
you keep hitting it and the longer
you're staying up there the less is
trading 900 702 and then just 59
and finally traders just gave up
and the market sold off it had a nice
sell-off from that
you know honestly you're not going to
sell it up here at 30 but you know you
once you start recognizing that you know
what this market is is bumping into a
high can't take it higher you know maybe
getting short in this bar here around um
you know 26 26 and a half you know worst
case maybe 25 but it gave you a very
quick move down to um you know 19
all right i mean literally two bars it
sells off you know from 25 down to 19
down to 20 down to 19 down to did hit 18
rallied back up
you know sort of to this lower level and
then you know sold off again but if
again if you're looking at a normal
footprint yeah you can see those volumes
now this is where it gets interesting
because if you're looking at a delta
footprint and you know i'm not saying
you got to flip around your charts all
day long no you just open up another
chart and have a delta footprint running
on it because i'm going to talk about
today is going to be very helpful
in your trading so
you can see the volumes it stands out
much clearer in here you can see the 911
the 702
right at the high of the day market
can't get past that that's a clear sign
that you know
at this point
traders have drawn a line in the sand
now that's not to say that you know the
market can sell off and then start
rallying back up build the ahead of
steam and go out and take it out because
it did do that you know conditions are
always
in the state of flux in the markets you
know new information comes in that
that's going to trade
its effect on the trading that's taking
place but if you're looking at a delta
footprint these volumes just really
stand out the 911 the 702. those are
very big volumes at any price level
in terms of i say volumes and talk about
delta right the difference between the
volume traded on the bid and the volume
traded on the offer at that price
because normally you're seeing you know
anywhere between you know 25 and 100 and
you know you'd consider anything over
100 already being on the high side you
know there's going to be some instances
where it's you know 300 169 you can see
300 here 363 there
but when you start seeing wow you know
911 782 at the same price you got to
start thinking what
effect does that have on the market
okay
now
a little bit later you know another one
of my favorite things to look for in the
market in terms of delta now again these
are not volumes at price these are
deltas at price the horizontal delta the
difference between the volume trade on
the bid the volume trade on the offer so
if you see here right there's 13.
so that's telling me that you know it's
a positive 13. now some software it'll
just have all the numbers on one side of
the bar either a positive or negative
you know so if it was negative it
obviously would be negative delta
meaning there's more negative more
aggressive selling than aggressive
buying but you can see here right 13
right in here is telling me there was 13
more aggressive buyers than
aggressive sellers at 39.28 whereas down
here it's -18 at 39 27 and a half so
it's telling me there was 18 more
aggressive sellers than buyers at this
price level okay now these are price
levels remember that it's not the bid
offer right it you could pull up a
diagonal delta if you wish
but what i'm referring to is just the
horizontal delta delta at price
now
one of the other things that i love to
look for is
sort of what i call like these these
pockets of
um
support or resistance so if i'm looking
at a delta bar
and
i see negative deltas i know obviously
there's aggressive selling but at the
same time
who is buying that
well you have
passive buyers there are people that are
working bids that the aggressive sellers
are selling into so
usually you know at the bottoms of moves
at the ends of moves you see you see
well you see the negative deltas you
think well there's selling down there
yeah but there was
but what you had is you had someone
absorbing it and
when i start to see you know these
clumps i don't can't think of the right
word right now the clusters or i like to
call them clumps
but like this green bar here right i see
this area between 27 and a half down to
25 as the market starts taking off so
this market has been basically going
sideways every time it sort of pokes
down right it's running into
passive buyers right there's aggressive
sellers but their selling is being
absorbed by the passive buying and the
markets rally back up finally you get
that big bar here
right where you got that passive buying
coming in here
right and the market rallies up with the
aggressive buying right people lifting
the offers and sort of you know on the
way out the way i like to call it you
know the
on the way out of the room
you see all this absorption in here okay
and it's a little bit higher level than
the absorption that came in here a
little bit higher than the absorption
that came in here
so i have this big area of absorption
right i like to just sort of make a
mental note of it this is like the last
area that has been touched before the
market moved out of that area
this is going to be an area where if the
market trades back into i want to see if
there's going to be some absorption
right you have another one right up in
here
just a little bit higher up
so i have another level of absorption
and we're holding it right you can see
we sort of came back in in this bar
right here and then this bar came right
down it traded through this
this area but then it stopped at this
area and you know this is where it gets
fascinating is because you know if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
right just you know the the normal
charts and you see markets pull back to
certain areas and then rally um you know
a lot of times you're sitting why did
the market pull back here well why
because you know there's probably some
absorption there earlier there was
nice passive buyers here willing to step
in and absorb what was happening here so
if i start seeing signs of absorption
right here okay
this area right in here absorption a
little bit higher new higher level
absorption a higher level absorption
another higher level of absorption the
market trades back into it
okay got through the first level but
second level is holding then the market
starts trading up okay you know i have a
bias being formed right market can
continue to rally up and it does right
rallies up into new highs
you know just keeps going higher and
today was a nice uh
obviously uptrending
day you know we closed up you know near
our highs of the day we did have some
sell-offs of course
um
excuse me
and you know i'll get to that
in a different video sort of talking
about
some of the things you want to look for
in the delta but you know when a market
is
trending right you're going to see bars
like this
right here bars like this so if it's
trending up where it's just pretty much
the whole bar is
everyone's lifting the offers there's
not much counter trade you don't have
you're not
left with much you know negative delta
on
the bid side right because everyone's
sort of stepping over themselves
buying it right you can see here right
you got the minus 29 here the minus
seven market is rallying up right here
boom everyone's just lifting every offer
in there right there they're
going you know take my money let me get
long right everyone's just super excited
you know even the next bar big areas in
here just all lifting offers this bar
here lifting all the offers
and you know we get up here to these
highs again we pull back a little bit
yeah there's a little bit of selling you
know you make new highs it's not
uncommon to see
some profit taking uh come into the
market but what was what got really
interesting was a little bit later in
the day
uh
after we made this high let me find it
here
uh what time was it
give me a sec losing track of my time
here
but it was a big volume
stepping into the market
gosh i
spent all day looking at these charts
here and
after a while they all look uh they all
look the same but it was a big volume
market came back to that level
to hold it
hey i'm going into sorry about this i
just gotta find it here
i
just can't remember what time it was i
thought it was around 1 30.
i think it's right in here somewhere
yeah here
12 51. so
mark is going up up up up okay and you
know it's going up on
normal
positive overflow
comes into this area right after we made
this high at 12 47
39 66 and a half
make another tick higher another tick
higher but what was interesting is
even though you know these bars got
negative delta you're not really pulling
off very much but this is where it got
very telling very revealing on what the
market was going to do next
as this market is going up it's people
basically lifting the offer right that's
what happens when markets move higher
people are lifting the offer
but all of a sudden now you've got
a big buyer stepping in right here at
39.65 and a half i mean you're sort of
getting that feeling when you start to
see these red bars come in but the
market's not selling off right it's just
coming off a little bit make a new high
doesn't even come off
lower than the previous bar then here
comes off a little bit and then someone
lifts all this offer right you see that
aggressive buying right these imbalances
are stacked in buying and balance coming
in here makes that new high comes off
from that high and a big buyer steps in
it's got negative delta of 4 62 okay
let's just uh that's 1251. let's go back
to the normal footprint chart and you
know this is why having a delta
footprint open
to see these things because again that
sort of thing doesn't happen all the
time you can see the volume it was 811
versus 349 right so that's what's giving
you that delta of 462 okay
at 39.65 and a quarter right right here
you have a new support level
right a big buyer stepped into the
market
what happens market makes a new high
red bar
green bar red bar red bar red bar red
bar comes right down to 65 okay i mean
you get 65 or 65 and a quarter rather
right here this level 65 and a half
actually but um 65 and a quarter i know
that i have buyers here one i can see i
got a stack buying about so i know i had
aggressive buyers here now not only did
i have the aggressive buyers that were
stepping in earlier i got a big
support level coming in here okay
i'm going to watch one if the stacked
mine and balance level is going to hold
and two if this big support level is
going to hold
right now that bid may not may still be
there may not be there who knows but i
know that there was buying you know
markets have a memory
when markets come back to a level the
market came right back to that level
obviously it held
and you know
then there were signs right the signs
that even though you're making these
highs markets not selling off so you
know there's some buying still taking
place up there even though there's
there's some decent selling
and that was the level right you see the
market finally reverse course and just
shot straight up i mean you know if
you're buying just you don't even have
to say well i'm going to work a bid in
here at 65 and a half you know
at this area in here now you're just
dropping a buy stop up here at 69 if the
market takes out this high at 68 and
three quarters because you're thinking
well you know i got a support area here
the high the day is right here
you know i am running into some bearish
information up here but
it i know i got this big support area so
what are you going to do right you want
to buy support and next thing is if you
can't buy support you start buying it
once the market starts moving away from
support and so you know you just drop
your buy stop in there at 69
and mark it you know almost a 10 point
move all the way up to 78 and three
quarters
right and what
happened next right the market came off
from 78 and three quarters came off back
down to that area right where you had
this stack buying and balance and that
big volume there so you know just
highlight the
imbalance
right so it's between you know
65 and a half and 64 and a quarter
market went up market came back where
right to that level
and you can see in here there's still
passive buying
all right the minus 182 minus 76 minus
46. it's all negative delta even in here
market went up a little bit came back in
minus 122 minus 179 oh sorry minus 79
and boom market went back up to the
highs
so
you know hopefully
you guys can appreciate
the value of delta and it's not just
using delta by itself i mean you know
you can see how using delta
you know that that came right after the
stacked imbalances it tells you really
that there's
there's interest at this level
okay and you know
honestly you know i get a kick out of
these guys you know that the post stuff
on fintwit but you don't need five you
know eight monitors no you don't really
need eight monitors but
there's nothing wrong with having a
couple of monitors on your desk you know
if you got one that's
you know a candlestick chart and one
that's running a footprint chart one
that's running a delta chart you know it
just gives you different perspectives on
the market
right you're not going to use the delta
chart trying to analyze every tick but
if you're going to see something like
this come in or what i showed you
earlier you know when you're at that
earlier high of the day with the heavy
volume then it's worth it all right i
mean yeah let people make fun of me for
having um you know a few monitors on
there because it's going to help me pick
up one or two of these trades a day that
can make the big difference in you know
your trading results
so again you know everybody thanks for
taking the time out to watch this video
be sure to like and subscribe my channel
i like the video subscribe to the
channel
and keep the comments coming you know
it's i'm probably going to do a video on
the comments so
you know
watch what you're right if uh you know i
i may choose it to be in a video so all
right guys have a great day and i'll
catch you guys tomorrow bye